[Music]
this morning on the dish if the produce
at one southern california restaurant
looks especially vibrant it's probably
because it didn't have to travel very
far jamie wax joins us
with a venue that gives farm to table a
whole new meaning jamie good morning
good morning dana that is true because
much of the produce for poppy and seed
is grown in a thriving greenhouse and
garden right on the restaurant's
property and chef and co-owner michael
reed takes it from there creating
inventive and tantalizing dishes that
are a ray of sunshine for both diners
and the community
this is called a buzz bun okay
so you can eat the whole thing but it's
going to overpower you just take a
little piece off of it chef michael
reed's outdoor garden is full of unique
ingredients put it on your tongue
you're going to start getting a tingling
sensation like pop rocks
that's
it's kind of crazy the 39 year old chef
calls this outdoor oasis his playground
and delights in using its fresh results
for his dishes it makes you salivate and
makes you hungry and makes you curious
like what did i just do
this is one of the craziest things i've
ever experienced the bright greenhouse
setting and courtyard of his poppy and
seed in anaheim california is surrounded
by lush herbs vegetables and edible
flowers what would you describe your
cooking as it's basically very seasonal
i've always loved italian i love french
i love asian foods so we basically get
to hide and snake certain ingredients
and to still be a california based
restaurant but build a lot of umami
flavors by using fermentation and
different ingredients that you normally
wouldn't find in most dishes to boost
that flavor i like to say we give you
something that's familiar
with a twist a twist you can taste in
dishes like seared scallops with pork
belly maitake mushrooms a celery root
puree and beluga lentils beluga lentils
are
a fancy lentil they have a little bit
more density and texture to it
once you put it all together it's a
perfect little bite the textures alone
are amazing but then the flavors
all start to meld in your mouth
shrimp and lobster risotto the colors
again and the freshness
of all the herbs on this are absolutely
phenomenal finished with mascarpone and
parmesan cheeses it's one of my
favorites to make here
also on the table crispy mushrooms with
an egg yolk topped with parmesan cheese
all right i'm going to break this
perfect egg yolk
look at that
oh
is that perfect
hand rolled three cheese tortellini and
broto avocado toast with pickled chilies
and shallots on sourdough bread ricotta
filled squash blossoms with herbs and
truffle honey crispy cheesy i'm sweet
yup that's the truffle of honey on top
raised in oxnard california reid credits
his parents for his green thumb at
garden growing up you know we had
blackberries my mom would make ice cream
we had peach trees avocado trees you
know artichokes my mom was always
growing stuff part of the punishment was
like if you didn't do your chores or you
got in trouble go to your garden pick
weeds and you're just like come on
now i really appreciate what they taught
me and you know
understanding that it takes a lot to
grow a lot of food but like many chefs
cooking for a living wasn't his first
dream i was on a track and field
scholarship i was a long distance runner
so i broke my foot had a bone chip
coach said i would never run as fast as
i would my freshman year i was like
you're right the olympics are gone kind
of shatter that drink and so when i
switched
motivation from being in a business
accounting in school to being like i
kind of had that plan b already lined up
being like
you don't really like school culinary
school seems more your speed i was
always cooking for the track team
reed would eventually land at the
prestigious culinary institute of
america went there did the two-year
program worked at the modern in new york
fell in love with fine dining in there
so then it snowed and i promptly moved
back to california
it took two years of driving upstate and
then back to manhattan
and then one big storm i was like before
it snows again i have to leave
grilled meatballs no bread scallops
mushroom butter lettuce after skipping a
couple of steps he became an executive
chef at 26 years
old you got that butter lettuce ready
right here
by 28 he was burnt out and had to
discover what not only fed his customers
but also fed his souls i like him i like
him i like him a little bit i love her
though
she may like me but i love her okay my
friends so you guys ordered some good
things he and his wife queenie opened a
popular la brunch spot called poppy and
rose with him as the chef and her on the
business side i respect him when i go
into the kitchen he's chef if i tell him
there's something that we can't buy
because we need to do x y and z or we're
falling short here or we've made really
good revenue here i need for you to look
at that he trusts me to say okay i
understand and we work together on
building this dream that we're building
together so is this moraine
the power couple are continuing to grow
their dream together with this space
that blossomed during a pandemic
i will say it was a traumatic experience
you know because this is our livelihood
and we also
hold other people's livelihoods in our
hands during the pandemic but i mean
where there's a lot of turmoil there's
also a lot of opportunity an opportunity
they use to give back to the community
we've seen homeless people walk past
here and pick off our garden and we have
no problems with it like please eat from
our garden it's here like if you find
something that's a tree you are you
hungry
pick something from it that's why it's
here it's here for us to give back and
it's here for him to create creativity i
mean with all your extensive knowledge
has it taught you something to grow your
own uh food here i'm still learning like
one of my pillars is you got to
constantly learn
you know it's all about really trying to
stay true to what it is instead of just
mass-produced food i want something
unique on the plate the only way to do
it is to sometimes grow it yourself and
like the food they've grown themselves
michael and queenie reed seem to always
be reaching toward the sun
i think it's essential for restaurants
and restaurant owners to stay positive
and give a safe warm inviting place for
people to come break bread have
memorable experiences
share stories and commune together
so you're doing your part we're doing
our small part there's always more that
we're looking to do but you know give us
time give us time and as we keep growing
we'll keep looking at the bigger
solutions of how we can get more engaged
in our communities and you know bring
people together
what a great story and a love story at
its heart they're so cute together it's
just complimentary so this food i mean
you can smell this oh it smells like
soda
michelle you're brave you have that buzz
button okay that that is what i tasted
in the beginning of the piece and it is
like it's kind of like pop rocks for
adults like natural
careful it's gonna burn a little and
then it'll make your mouth go numb
unique burn and then make your mouth go
numb that's what you want to hear oh it
does make my mouth go numb can you read
it you guys
oh i have a tease coming up
oh wow good timing
is it time
are we still talking
it must be time
i love it
you can try it wow oh there we go
oh i love it it comes in wet this is the
ticket everybody